previously on the forest why is this
door not opening
it it looks like there's a wall on the
other side isn't there just like a holy
deconstruct
thing is that a thing that's not a thing
come to me right now
is there a way to cross that river with
a sled you think did you get across with
your
thingy no i'm building a bridge guys i
just want to say i built a really sweet
bridge
oh my bridge oh god no mark where'd your
bridge go
i dropped a tree on it i like this
bridge man there's a br it's a heck of a
bridge
the last bridge was like two pieces it
was very well put together it's fine
into the watermark
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
hey i'll lead him watch this i'm a hero
come to me
he jumped over it can we use our
chainsaws to injure them oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah
hey hey hey yeah he doesn't like that
very much
how do you what do you think about that
out right in the dick oh you were going
to punch me
yeah you thinking about it i didn't
think so
well i didn't mark please for the love
of god build a wall i'm thinking we
might need layers of defense
yeah no layers of defense sounds great
because this sounds like it's about to
get pretty spicy out here
there we go okay mark's outside
i don't know what's happening to mark
but i'm concerned okay why is it sleepy
time junction yet is this
well let's go take a nap boys all right
um so we're gonna show up the bridge
before we keep working up top there is
that the plane right now we probably
should fix that yeah
yeah yeah that is an issue there's got
to be a way to happy birthday this right
oh is this the trap idea
yeah so i'm making a like a side path
that we could get the
card around and then if we need to we
maybe we'll hit that i don't know if
they will but i was thinking of one
option i don't know if it'll work
isn't there like a a pulley lever system
where you can have like a platform that
goes up and down like an elevator
could we just have one part of the
bridge be lifted yeah
before all hell broke loose that's
exactly what i was trying to say mark
that's wondering if we could make a
drawbridge with the with the
crane thing right because that would
work like that right yeah
so you just need like a structure up top
with stairs that go to the safe side
and then like make a make an upper part
and then crane down to the lower part
now that i think that would work
right that's brain in pretty good guys
you said it out loud first so
i'm not at all offended if it's your
idea i just told you i literally was
trying to say that while we were fleeing
from the invincible [ __ ] man what if
we cut a hole
oh wait someone's coming someone's
coming someone's coming
okay this might destroy
everything there's a bunch of rocks out
here i'm currently filling up the rock
holders
okay i'm about to do the same dumb thing
i did before
don't do that oh is this the crane yeah
so
i don't know how it works i just wanted
to get it down so i see
what does this do what am i doing
it lowered a little bit
wait is this as high as a oh no oh
so we're gonna have to build oh god okay
so it needs to be higher right
yeah i need to build like a platform up
do you want me to destroy the crane
no no well yeah we'll eventually have to
destroy all of it
we aren't going to get that rope back so
i don't think that's breaking art
what if i got to drop a tree on it is
that what i have to do
yeah this is breaking it i broke it
it doesn't look broken to me why is this
so much more durable to us than it was
for them they went and sneezed and our
[ __ ] whole wall came in
ah wasn't it is this one
better wait put a hole in it that'll
break it
if we've learned anything about the
whole thing it's that the whole thing
definitely just destroys everything
oh no oh come on
see why didn't it do that when i was
looking at the gazebo
come on come on
come on close this come on
oh no i thought mark how did you make an
indestructible bridge what did you do
there she goes
okay oh my gosh
i guess we get those logs back dude why
don't we get these logs back
i don't know man i don't know yeah oh
you're doing it differently okay i was
just grabbing if you
if you strafe right and spam grab
you uh you you scooch it why are you
building stairs on this side oh i see
what you're doing
what no you do it i'm not questioning
you engineer
bob's inclination was correct bob's
inclination was correct i'm glad you're
acknowledging my inclinations
do the engineering don't do the work let
us let the men do the work
let the adults touch the stuff okay you
just
you just draw your pretty little
pictures
well now it sounds condescending though
try to get into the conversation
walls make a big gate if you hit r on it
before you build
where are you hearing that from uh
there's a bird that flew by it landed on
my tentacle armor don't
trust those birds don't trust them all
right mark while you're doing this
i'm gonna stick the ground and get some
rocks over here all right sounds good
man sounds good
gotta make sure i got all that slang
shot ammo and all the coins that come
out of the
dude people who work jobs are idiots
get yourself a stick get yourself some
old t-shirts and wrap them around that
stick
stab the ground and you will literally
dig up
all the money you will ever need i'm not
a logs
if you finish your engineering we can
put them on from the other side well no
probably not
yeah i need that i need to get ups build
the drawbridge then i'll build a bridge
i'm gonna take one of these sleds
there's logs over on the other end of
our little area
i'm just gonna go deforest the rest of
this you know okay best of luck
if i find another human crab i'm [ __ ]
done
there's a rock in the water you can
fully parkour over here from the rock
okay good move good move good move oh oh
my god i just realized the angle's off
is it how many logs are you all wasting
over there no it's fine it's fine we're
gonna make it work
that's workable yeah it's not bad but
the approach yeah it's fine we'll make
it work it's fine
it's just fine okay so if i oh why is it
so crooked it's so crooky
oh but then it pluck i can raise it
was it working oh my god are you winning
son
okay but that's not the right angle uh
this but the staircase to get
okay can we walk can we move oh okay
all right okay all right okay
okay all right okay okay
okay all right i'm currently looking at
the fact that this
this goopy sticky gross arm armor
there's like veins or intestines that
tie it to your forearm
and you know what i very cleverly
allowed myself to be injured by that man
so i wouldn't have to look at or think
about it anymore so if you could please
stop subscribing smart of you that was
very smart i would appreciate that
okay this looks good stunning success
even
uh it's a little uneven and it's bugging
me
so it's slightly off i'm redoing it are
these where you actually want us to
start building
no no no no i've ruined it i've ruined
it i gotta start over again
oh god oh god it's gotta be perfect
i don't think that build the drawbridge
don't look at me
okay what no oh
accidentally made a little nubbins i
made a nubbins on it i made a nubbins it
was
not perfect it was not perfect i swear
it you would have hated it no i think it
would have been fine
because it would have existed how do we
get more cloth is it just do we just get
that from going to the camps their their
camps and grabbing it was that how we
were getting yeah
yeah there's lots in the camps oh my god
there's so many rocks
over here i'm gonna fill this sled with
as many rocks as humanly possible
mark i yes love you
and you're doing great work but how long
is this going to take
the engineering is only half the battle
don't no is it is it
oh my god what could you possibly not be
happy with
beautiful mark look at that i needed to
make it one wide or so that it would
even on both sides
shot i got one shot a chance one
opportunity i can no longer see the
other side so i'm doing this one blind
guys i figured out how you stock rocks
how do you stock rocks
with a sled you sled the rocks and stock
them with the slime
and i'm cold i'm gonna go home it's
probably because you're soaking wet
what happened am i going i'm dying of
hunger and thirst
i'm fine yeah you got you gotta eat a
brilliant mind man
i'm fine to find this is a much better
idea
if i build it from the side where there
already is the bridge i can just
line it up perfectly and uh that's true
that's true actually never mind oh it
won't let me we should test to make sure
a slug can actually go on this because
there's a bit of a gap here
we can always build another platform on
the other side that'll that'll match
that up so i'm not
too concerned about that side
but i am concerned about this side
uh mark there's glowing fire behind you
in the woods i have time
i don't know where they went but they're
over there okay
this is the one there's a bunch of
skulls and i don't really know
do we can we build skull storage it's
just a thing
i don't even know what we can use i
guess we use them for totems and some of
the weapons but i don't know what else
skin rack armor rack arrow basket bone
basket
maybe they can play bone basket oh god
why oh someone please light
i'm one click away from getting it but
i'm shaking because i'm cold
i think you're alone dude got it okay
oh it's fine that was my last shot
we should go to sleep mark you're ready
for a nap yeah yeah i'm coming back
oh yeah anyway i'm gonna build us some
storage in the base
god all right i'm sleeping are we
sleeping is sleeping already
yes hello you guys sleep i mean it's
almost morning we might as well stay
awake at this point
oh i'm already in bed broseph i mean
this just means that the next night
we're gonna push our sleep even farther
back so
ah that's true all right you talked me
out of it all right well let's just warm
up around the campfire then shall we
yeah that sounds good
you want to hear a ghost story song i
would like a ghost story song
i know a guy called jimmy big bones
used to wear these giant headphones
and then one day his headphones didn't
fit so jimmy went
down shopping but the butcher
he was chopping he killed jimmy
and no one else knows [ __ ] what's my
song
what what song you guys enjoyed it were
you
what did you do before you came on this
island wade what was your job
oh carpenting carpenter used to build
houses
uh sometimes over suspicious dirt mounds
in yards
but so long as you weren't a butcher
right you weren't i didn't really want
to get into the family business you know
i'm gonna finish this bridge all right
see you guys uh out there when i'm done
wait i see the fires you were referring
to
um yeah possibly problematic all the
logs are over there and i want them
but they're there so
are there bad guys over by you uh on the
other side the bridge isn't done yet so
uh
we're okay for now i'm just gonna raise
this
up i love this lift this
this drawbridge idea is is stellar but
there are
definitely people on the other side of
this i guess i don't know what else
skulls are for
it's yeah it's basically just totems or
um decoratives
or the the what there's one weapon the
one like melee weapon you can make
what i don't know yeah i don't know what
totems oh god
what oh oh no guys please come quick
mark are you in some sort of trouble oh
my god please come quick now
okay we're going buddy they can throw
fire oh are they burning down your
bridge
no you get in the water they they miss
but
they were they can throw fire
i was unaware that they could throw a
fire they're on the
right away they can throw fire mark
i see you constructing a new bridge oh i
see him over there
no it's not it's the same bridge i
didn't finish it before okay
okay but you see the error but i'm gonna
leave it there because it's a bit of
charm but
i'm not happy about it that bridge is
perfectly lined up
except for the nubbins and i hate the
nubbins
what nubbin oh i see what nubins are
talking about yeah it's gonna
bug me every single time we cross this
bridge yeah the nubbins kind of look
like [ __ ] and i i wish you'd lined it up
a little bit better but honestly
you did pretty good thank you i tried
you can call it
honestly for for a first time bridge
builder you're doing pretty damn good i
mean this is technically
my third bridge but you wear headphones
very often
oh you know on a kid you got a lot of
bones you're wearing you know
yeah you kind of wear what you can find
and sometimes you just have a
corpse and you know it's like i'm gonna
dig a hole or just toss on a fire and
then also there's a bunch of bones and
it's like
i could go hunt some lizards or you
could just wear the bones of our fallen
enemies you know
[Music]
i was supposed to be getting more cloth
that's the thing i remember now
yeah i could go into the camp away from
waiting uh
go go i'll go get it yeah i'll go with
it yeah no
no wait no you say there you go you're
doing god's work
oh i'm almost out of cloth though no
i'll get i'll get some for how much you
need
oh i don't know 50 60 all right gotcha
yeah i'll get
all right cool cool in a bit then later
mark where are we gonna go
i don't know i don't know i think he
killed i think he
i think he's the guy the big bold guy
do you think he's the one who killed my
son is your son dead do we know for sure
i mean it's definitely dead at this
point i just don't know how it happened
it's been like two weeks
yeah it's been it's been a while kids
can't survive on their own that long
actually not timmy's [ __ ] idiot
was i got a picture a kid's drawing of
someone
giving a gun to a child very confusing
cool i dip my hand in paint
hi wade what brings you to this camp uh
it's not a picture what is that what was
that sound i just started like
probably someone with eight legs you
know creeping up behind you probably it
was
six legs okay pretty sure it was eight
i'm pretty sure you don't even know how
to count oh uh this
town is occupied yeah this town is
occupied by the way
oh boy there you go where are you guys
oh you guys are over there well you're
at the you're at the place where the
cloth
is yeah i'm getting the cloth but i'm
currently being pursued
yeah i really appreciate you clearing
this out made a lot easier for me to get
some cloth
you're welcome whoa oh there's an
athlete over here too mark there's more
gas yeah that's great okay
i'm going back to the bridge is he still
behind me
uh yeah oh you're welcome
oh mark he brought friends you wanna
help me jesus no no no i don't no
actually no i'm uh busy with my own
stuff
all right oh eight legs oh eight legs
wait one let me count one two three
bob was right it was six
well if he's dead or at least i'm happy
to know that he knows i was right
oh yeah i see it oh god it's six legs
right it's
six it is six wait can you confirm that
get real close
you confirm that for us one two three
four five i see five
man this one's number six
god this drawbridge would oh it's not
you didn't
you didn't sit next to the bridge you
got you just
why did you know there's a charger
why didn't you finish the bridge are you
guys we have camp along we have a hop a
long path
oh my god yeah we gotta hop on guys all
right oh my god oh it nailed me
oh what is that big baby
what is that he's like you guys are just
being magic
oh don't don't you dare you're [ __ ]
no we're fine we're fine we're fine i
don't know what happened it did a belly
flop and then i never saw it again so i
guess it ran away either way i'm gonna
finish this bridge i guess
wait how did that just happen what mark
i have concerns about the bridge
oh it's not done that's what he said oh
it's not constructed
but there's no it looks 100 done doesn't
it no no watch this
now it's oh baby what actual
perfection is this oh it's so close
it's so close but hey it works right
yeah that's beautiful i love this gap
isn't a problem that's the only thing
is there a card over here already yeah
there is right here well this just looks
terrible
okay let me uh let me make this real
quick
oh i'm stuck oh god
hey hey everything the hell man
i'm driving the bliss oh god who gave me
a license
should we keep the stairs is that a way
for them to like get over to us
no i think those are fine it's the
ramparts you know
yeah yeah it's the ramparts or the
ramparts we watched you know you know
what i'm saying
wow we well we gallantly streaming
yeah they're gallons i'm gallantly
streaming i don't know what you guys are
doing oh we're gallantly streaming i
feel pretty gallant that's everyone's
vocab word of the day
gallant what's it mean you might ask
[ __ ] googly lazy shits
when you buy milk at the grocery store
that's a gallant of milk
[Laughter]
i [ __ ] knew that would make you laugh
hey mark i got this for you
all right i had to build it stupid but
you know this whole thing is stupid so
you didn't build it stupid at all dude
it's amazing
that's fine we just need two more logs
well nobody liked my gallant of milk
joke come on
that was fine it was good oh i hate it
oh
see you're sending mixed signals here
mark i gotta be honest i'm gonna stick
us
so hard you're gonna oh
i'm gonna i'm gonna make a sledge full
of sticks hang on this is the real test
i feel like right here
and it's not done okay uh oh oh oh oh
oh no no no no no no
no no no no i have some i have some
complaints
oh god in heaven what's happened to me
okay all right what's the problem what's
the complaint what's the convince
what is what is that what is happening
it won't go where are you going where
are you going
where are you going where are you going
i don't know man bad stuff is happening
man
i don't know maybe i need to wait no
i've got it
mark you can fix it if you just go like
this and then fall onto it
and then the sledge does that and then
you oh no
and then you hang on hang on i got this
hang on hang on i got this are you and
then you're like
sledge oh goodness me oh there we go
nope
didn't do it is it all the way i get to
i can fix it mark hang on i've
if you if you if you just use these
stairs
this is fine this will be fine this will
be fine you just force it up to the top
of these stairs
parkour style hang on hang on this will
work this will work this will work
i'm saving it mark i'm saving your i'm
saving your beautiful bridge
and then you go like this and then go
over here
okay there we go oh look mark it works
hey i did not break anything oh it
doesn't work from this side
mark we're gonna need more stairs
so you're telling me this car just
doesn't go on drawbridges
is that what i'm understanding here
what if we cut a hole in the drawbridge
will that fix it
man we really should have tested that
[ __ ] oh
can you build the bridge foundation part
any higher do you have any control over
that because i think the problem is that
the hitbox for the
the lifty part is just higher than the
sliding hitbox
bridge part okay can you can you build
it any higher up well let's
experiment with this small nub inside
because yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah if it doesn't work
here then
i'm gonna take some time to fill this
with sticks
and you fix it in the meantime
okay there that's gonna be fine mark
it's gonna be fine
don't worry about it dude i swear
i put all that effort i thought it was
going to be a funny joke for a second i
didn't think it was just not going to
work well i wish
case we could sled to here and then just
empty the [ __ ] out into another
yeah we can have a one side sled and
another side sled and we'll just have to
we'll just have to have different side
sleds it's a workaround to our
stupid workaround we just had a normal
bridge i can't believe we had a normal
bridge and we're like maybe we put a
door on it
no listen
ambition in engineering is not a is not
a fault
it's be you're you're you're ahead of
your time sir
yeah we just didn't take into account
stupid
stupidness of not being able to take a
[ __ ] sled across this goddamn
thing we need four more for separation
this one's off
but eight yeah oh
don't you six or seven or eight legs
some number i can't tell
some number of legs is coming oh uh do
you get it
okay uh don't have this oh i gotta get
the sled
wait but we can't test it from that side
that's not how this works
it's like oh they're throwing fire yeah
time to go
oh god i'm sorry i'm coming no there's
fire on it oh there's so many stumps
i'm dodging quick this come on this is
my top speed
so you can't go from that side i just
want to let you know
yeah ah
[Music]
there's so many sticks on there mark
there's so many sticks wait can you
i can't seem to save anything
that i build but you
can still save your money this video is
sponsored by yada savings and i know
when i say savings that sounds
really boring but yadda's mission is to
somehow make saving money fun
and the mad lad somehow managed to
actually do it i use yada myself
i love it i find myself checking it
every night to see if i've actually won
a prize
and that's all it is it's a savings
account and the more money that you save
the more chances you have to win a prize
bad time air conditioner
that's it there's no buying anything
you're not buying chances you're saving
money it's your money it's fdic insured
there's free there's no fees you still
collect 0.2 percent a year
and you get chances to win more money
it's really cool because saving actually
is important
at least that's what my dad said long
time ago when i was just a kid he signed
me up for a bank account and he
recommended me the importance of
compound interest but the bank took a
fee anyway it was five dollars i only
had fifteen dollars in the bank account
then five dollars could take it away if
you'd like to try it there's a link in
the description below you can use code
markiplier when you sign up for bonus
chances to win prizes
and when you do get in use code
markiplier again to find my prize pool
that i made and we can pool our chances
together
for even more chances to win to be
perfectly honest it's not going to be
wildly different than any normal savings
account but the habit is the more
important thing and that's what i really
like about it saving is actually
important
as much as my dad was yammering on about
it is kind of important so
link in the description code markiplier
for both the pool and signing up
[Music]
you